erst gab es die oster ruhe mitten in der
nacht beschlossen dann die große
entschuldigung der kanzlerin
und jetzt fragen sich alle was kommt
denn nun ausgangssperren oster mega
lockdown alles liegt wieder auf dem
tisch und die kanzlerin
die hat in einem vorab aufgezeichneten
interview mit anne will bereits gesagt
was sie möchte
wir wissen schon was sie dort gesagt hat
ja und einer dieser sätze den angela
merkel in dem vorab aufgezeichneten
interview bei anne will gesagt hat ist
ich werde nicht 14 tage lang tatenlos
zusehen die kanzlerin gerade in einem
vorab aufgezeichneten interview mit anne
will dort hat sie auch gesagt dass
natürlich ausgangssperren auf dem tisch
sind ich möchte über das und vieles
andere sprechen mit meinen gästen mit
dabei sind heute der verkehrsminister
andreas scheuer op von tübingen boris
palmer klaus stöhr virologe und bernd
buchholz fdp-wirtschaftsminister schönen
guten abend herr scheuer wenn sie das
sehen was die kanzlerin dort bei anne
will gleich sagen wird muss man sagen
weil das war ja ein vorab
aufgezeichneten interview
sie wird nicht tatenlos zusehen und
ausgangssperren sind auf dem tisch was
glauben sie was wird jetzt in
deutschland passieren was wissen sie was
will die kanzlerin ja keiner wille
tatenlos zusehen wir haben ja eine ganze
bandbreite von maßnahmen die ja auch
schon in den beschlüssen der
ministerpräsidenten mit der
bundesregierung am tisch liegen
es hat sich auch an dieser stelle nicht
diametral los verändert sondern wir
haben ja über kontakt beschränkungen und
ausgangssperren geredet und sie auch
beschlossen bei verschiedenen instanzen
geht es auch nicht anders keiner will 14
tage tatenlos zusehen
ich glaube das ist parteiübergreifender
konsens aber nur sich die kanzlerin das
dann in einem interview so klar noch
einmal sagen meint sie damit die
ministerpräsidenten meint sie damit die
menschen in deutschland die aus ihrer
sicht nicht mehr mitmachen wer ist damit
gemeint ist
ich glaube mir vorher immer die frage
wissen auf jeden fall ist die letzte
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ja nicht
gut gelaufen und die auswirkungen waren
ja auch klar letzte woche viel
diskutiert ich würde auch nicht den
begriff knallhart lockdown nehmen das
ist vielleicht eine sprache die ihnen
sie liegt aber ich würde sagen wir
brauchen maßnahmen weil wir ja sehen
frankreich meldet gerade höchste instanz
werte wir haben selber 25 prozent
zugelegt in den letzten tagen von den
infektionszahlen her
das kann keinen ruhig lassen und das
macht glaube ich auch sinn darüber zu
reden was jetzt die wichtigen maßnahmen
sind wissen sie wie sehr dieser wenn ich
das noch sagen darf dieser
flickenteppich jeder macht jetzt vor
sich hin
der muss zusammengeführt werden in eine
einige strategie eine einigkeit in
dieser dramatische lage weil das problem
ist emotional und psychologisch wir
sehen eigentlich noch nicht das ziel
und wir reden aber immer schon drüber
und jetzt kommt die verunsicherung und
das möbel seien und deswegen müssen wir
uns echt konzentrieren jetzt die
nächsten 14 tage jetzt entscheidend
werden ob wir gut dann in den in den
sommer starten können herr palmer sie
sind zum star geworden muss man sagen in
deutschland gibt keinen politiker der
das modell tübing nicht genannt hat in
den letzten wochen sogar markus söder
hat sie dort genannt weil der
pressekonferenz in der letzten woche ich
möchte ihnen denn noch bevor wir
sprechen noch einmal zeigen was die
kanzlerin außerdem gesagt hat in diesem
vorab aufgezeichneten interview bei
anne will da liegen uns weitere sätze
vor die kanzlerin hat gesagt die
bundesländer sind alle einzeln auf der
basis unserer mpk beschlüsse mit mir mit
der bundesregierung in der lage aus dem
instrumentenkasten das richtige
herauszufiltern und für sich zu nehmen
und außerdem hat sie gesagt und deshalb
brauchen wir im augenblick keine mpk
sondern wir brauchen handeln in den
ländern da werde ich mir anschauen ob
das reicht herr palmer was bedeutet das
hat die kanzlerin ein bisschen
aufgegeben was diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz angeht die
am fiasko im desaster geendet ist beim
letzten mal
tut mir leid da fühle ich mich wirklich
nicht kompetent ihnen zu antworten ich
kenne sie nicht habe noch nie mit ihm
persönlich gesprochen und ich weiß auch
nicht was sie da im schilde führt was
wäre aus ihrer sicht wenn man jetzt sagt
es soll keine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz stattfinden
wäre aus ihrer sicht ist richtig ist
mehr regional zu machen bei ihnen in
tübingen gibt es ja viele modelle dort
kann man sogar schon in bars wieder
gehen dort kann man sitzen wenn man
getestet ist was wir aus ihrer sicht
jetzt das richtige was sollten wir in
deutschland tun
angesichts der tatsächlich stark
steigender werte einerseits glaube ich
dass man durchaus den kommunen mehr
vertrauen entgegenbringen kann dass sie
vor ort organisieren was dort heißt und
wichtig ist nach dieser methode sind wir
in tübingen in dieser zweiten und jetzt
auch in der dritten welle vorgegangen
und haben zum beispiel unser schnelltest
konzept aufgesetzt und das prinzip
möglichst viele leute zu testen indem
man ihnen angeboten
wenn sie wenn sie jetzt sagen das sei
das richtige modell in dem zusammenhang
was muss man denn tun gegen die zahl
gegen welche zahl ist für ihn die hoch
steigenden infektionszahlen in den
vergangenen tagen ja also ich hab gerade
versucht zu erläutern dass unser modell
darin besteht möglichst viel zu testen
indem man menschen angebote macht die
sie wahrnehmen wollen nachdem sie sich
sehen und dafür den test zur
voraussetzung machen kommen wir jetzt in
tübingen mittlerweile auf etwa einen
halben test pro woche pro einwohner also
jeder zweite einwohner wird einmal in
der woche getestet ist noch nicht genug
aber sehr sehr hoher wert im
deutschlandweiten vergleich und ich
glaube dass damit so viele fälle
entdeckt werden können dass man
infektionsketten abbrechen kann und
damit auch die pandemie unter kontrolle
bringt aber auch wir müssen da noch
zulegen und mehr testen also fälle
finden und töten abbrechen ist das eine
und das andere und dann können wir
kommunal nichts machen da wäre die
kanzlerin selbst gefordert wäre endlich
eine wirksame nachverfolgung mit
moderner technik zu ermöglichen ich hab
ja davon zwei monaten im brief
geschrieben und sie gebeten doch
zumindest vortragsweise eine tracing app
programmieren zu lassen also eine die
unsere problems profile aufzeichnet und
im bedarfsfall ins gesundheitsamt
übermittelt sodass man nachvollziehen
kann mit wem infizierte kontakt hatten
diese beiden maßnahmen zusammen würden
uns durch die nächste welle bringen ohne
dass wir wieder in dem dropdown müssen
herr stöhr warum gibt es diese modelle
immer noch nicht in deutschland sie
haben auch immer wieder darauf verwiesen
dass wir auf modernere mittel
zurückgreifen müssen jetzt in dem
interview bei anne will hat die
kanzlerin wieder ausgangs beschränkungen
spiel gebracht kontakt beschränkungen
und hat diesen satz gesagt wir sie wird
sich das 14 tage nicht tatenlos ansehen
was bedeutet das für uns alle
also wahrscheinlich ganz zusammen auf
der einen seite heißt das wer wird nicht
14 tage zu sehen auf der anderen seite
hörig von dem was sie sagen dass man
sagt okay
die länder müssen
jetzt an und dezidiert regional
eigentlich die sache wieder auf kurs
bringen
für mich entscheiden die fakten und
zahlen und auch die erfahrung bei der
bekämpfung ist immer regional ist
saisonal und konzentriert auf die
risikogruppen
wir haben ja auch nun nach zwölf monaten
gesehen dass in einigen kreisen wo man
regional agiert hat nicht nur in
tübingen auch in rostock münster anderen
bessere ergebnis hatte also anderswo man
als vielleicht durch regiert hatte oder
von oben versucht seine allgemeine
strategie umzusetzen
ich kann auch nicht verstehen dass man
glaubt durch seine lange pandemie mit
einer maßnahme gehen zu wollen viele
sagen juli auch wenn ab das ist normal
bei einer pandemie darf man sich
anpassen muss es die ist saisonal auch
stark bedingt die risikogruppen sind
unterschiedlich also hier muss man
wirklich regional saisonal und auf die
risikogruppen eingehen und dass das
jetzt durch kommt finde ich gut
man sieht ja aber auch an den fans dass
in den bundesländern es unheimlich
unterschiedlich ist
wir sehen in schleswig holstein eine
abfallende sterberate weniger als zwei
fälle pro 100000 auf der intensivstation
und in mecklenburg vorpommern den wir
vier fünf fälle pro 100000 ansteigender
trend ja sollen die beiden länder jetzt
gleich agieren nein hier muss man
regional ran und das wird glaube ich
auch in zukunft viel wichtiger und
hoffentlich auch noch mehr ergebnisse
bringen als bis jetzt
er bereut sie kommen aus schleswig
holstein sind dort wirtschaftsminister
wenn sie jetzt hören dass die kanzlerin
im interview bei anne will sagt zitat
für mich sind weitere kontakt
beschränkungen ausgangs beschränkungen
ganz wichtige mittel um das
exponentielle wachstum zu stoppen + test
strategien in den schulen und durch die
wirtschaft was geht ihnen da durch den
kopf bedeutet dass die nächsten monate
stehen wir im ewig lockt da ganz
bedeutet zunächst einmal das ist man
sich eigentlich wünschen würde dass es
differenziertere herangehensweisen geben
würde nach einem jahr der pandemie dass
wir auch das hören würden was das rp was
die tu berlin alle aufschreiben und
sagen wo das tatsächliche geschehen
stattfindet da war es tatsächlich
unterbunden werden muss und was
eigentlich
zum pandemie geschehen nichts beiträgt
oder ein geringeres infektionsrisiko hat
und da muss man eben aufpassen dass man
immer nur mit einem harten locker und im
zweifel die akzeptanz der menschen
verliert statt sie im zweifel auch
machen zu lassen an bestimmten stellen
wo es dann halt risikoloser ist ich
glaube es ist viel gefährlicher wenn
sich menschen in ihren privaten räumen
zu ostern wechselseitig besuchen als
dass man eine außengastronomie öffnet
und sagt menschenskinder jetzt durch
doch nachmittags in der sonne
gegebenenfalls mit zwei meter abstand
gegenüber
da habt ihr mehr was davon das heißt
also dinge aufzuzeigen die möglich sind
unter palmer hat ja gesagt
testen testen so lange wir nicht impfen
impfen können was in wahrheit natürlich
ein desaster ist dass wir nicht so
schnell impfen können wie andere aber
dann geht testen und ja eins stimmt die
länder haben eigentlich einen
werkzeugkasten aus dem heraus sie
handeln können auch in einem bundesland
wie schleswig-holstein das nur sehr
geringe inzidenz nach wie vor hat von
etwa 68 heute ist es der differenz
zwischen einem 20 instanz kreis
nordfriesland und einem über 100 kreis
flensburg oder woanders
also da muss man unterschiedlich
herangehen und deshalb muss noch länder
unterschiedlich dar eingreifen wichtig
ist nur dass sie es konsequent tun und
wenn man dann hört dass die berühmte
notbremse von dem ministerpräsidenten
zwar beschlossen wird aber wenn einige
länder über 100 gehen nichts passiert
dann fragt man sich schon warum die
ganzen beschlüsse sie sprechen die
beschlüsse an ein großes thema bei der
letzten mpk und ein thema was uns in den
nächsten tagen und wochen beschäftigen
wird bleibt der urlaub und da haben wir
heute besondere fotos erlebt unter
anderem aus gran canaria dort gab es
einen extrem vollen strand da hat man
das gefühl gehabt die pandemie ist nicht
mehr so richtig dort zumindest nicht auf
gran canaria da liegt man eng an eng die
sonne scheint wahrscheinlich sehen wir
uns alle danach endlich mal wieder so am
strand liegen zu können aber es stellt
sich natürlich die frage was bedeutet
dass herr scheuer sie als
verkehrsminister machen sie sich sorgen
wenn sie solche vollen strände sehen und
wenn sie hören dass allein heute 30
flieger aus deutschland auf mallorca
gelandet sind
deswegen haben wir vorkehrungen
getroffen mit den entscheidungen zur
einreise voraussetzung also bei der
wiedereinreise nach deutschland ist ein
negativer tests
das finde ich richtig daran haben wir
intensiv gearbeitet
wenn jetzt wer in den urlaub fliegt das
kann man jetzt gut finden oder schlecht
naja ob das jetzt angebracht ist bei
denen zahlen ich will noch mal
hervorheben wir tun ja immer in
deutschland sowie werden die die
schlechtesten werden
wir haben jetzt eine instanz von 135000
wir verweisen darauf frankreich 382
polen 482 italien 259 ungarn 652 und
österreich 251 und jetzt streiten wir
richtigerweise über den richtigen weg
damit wir noch weiter runter kommen oder
anders gesagt nicht sprunghaft ansteigt
aber das ist eine frage des
urlaubsplaner ja und da komme ich jetzt
drauf und damit das nicht sprunghaft
ansteigen für leute die wiedereinreise
nach deutschland weit jetzt einen urlaub
machen wollen haben wir bei der einreise
verordnung es zur grundvoraussetzung bei
der wiedereinreise gemacht dass ein
negativer test vorliegen
ich glaube das ist auch im großen die
strategie die halme fährt wir müssen
wenn wir nicht jetzt eine höhere rate
jetzt zu dem zeitpunkt haben das wird
jetzt auch die nächsten board und massiv
ansteigen
testen testen testen in den betrieben
bei den reisenden und vieles mehr
also das heißt das wird die strategie
seien ja ich bin ja dabei bei diesen
regionalen lösungen ich glaube wir sind
an manchen stellen zu perfektionistisch
typisch deutsch angegangen wir brauchen
mehr pragmatismus und bevor wir eine mpk
brauchen brauchen wir glaube ich eher
einen digital rat er mal alle diese
initiativen die jetzt zur nachverfolgung
da sind und am tisch liege mal zusammen
sammelt und auch mal die diskussion
darüber führt wie wir die krone at
besser nutzen können ich glaube wenn ein
grundsatz ist dass wir ein stück unserer
grundfreiheiten wieder schneller
zurückbekommen muss es kompromisse beim
datenschutz geben daran sind viele viele
initiativen gescheitert also wir
brauchen sie
er hat gesagt in den vergangenen tagen
andere werkzeuge als ein lockdown stehen
uns nicht zur verfügung wie peinlich ist
das für einen standort wie deutschland
das ein jahr nach beginn der pandemie
uns immer noch nichts anderes als dieser
lockt zur verfügung steht ja ich finde
diese begriffe irgendwie ziemlich
schwierig wenn man von deplatziert und
knallhart und noch mal eine schippe
drauflegen gibt wir über wir über bieten
uns jetzt und das finde ich nicht gut
weil
und dann möchte man immer ihr konzert
gewerbeschau das geht ja darum dass er
wieder sagt wir haben nur die
möglichkeit leute also sinngemäß
einzusperren und auf kontakte zu
verzichten weil wir eben in all den
anderen bereichen nicht vorangekommen
sind erst einmal wir sind ja
vorangekommen
nur der hintergrund daran ist warum
jetzt die schärfe zugenommen hat wir
spüren es doch bei unseren verwandten
und bekannten die eine gruppe ist für
schließen manche sagen lockdown die
andere gruppe ist für lockern schnell
perspektive geben und dann gibt es
irgendwo dazwischen uns auch nicht
passieren dass das virus ziemlich
gesundheitliche schäden und tote
verursacht hat dass wir auch noch in
unserer gesellschaft eine lagerbildung
erleben die wir so nicht mehr zusammen
führen können
und das muss jetzt die einigkeit seien
unter den ländern beim bund unter den
parteien einigkeit um über die einigkeit
im vorgehen diesen virus zu besiegen und
das ist mein ansinnen auch was meine
aufgaben sind bei der mobilität beim
reisen es nachvollziehbar machen
erklärbar machen bis viele
flickenteppich und durcheinander hat ja
dazu geführt dass sich die leute zum
schluss gar nicht ausgekannt haben weil
sie einen beipackzettel des eigenen
verhaltens brauchen und deswegen
brauchen wir gerade botschaften und die
klare botschaft ist die nächsten 14 tage
werden sehr sehr schwierig und wir
werden maßnahmen ergreifen müssen damit
wir nach dem 15 april wirklich
perspektive geben können
und wenn wir die zeit die 14 tage jetzt
verlieren dann werden wir nach dem 15
april alle darunter leiden das will ich
sie sprechen das reisen an herrscher das
ist ihre aufgabe sie haben darauf
hingewiesen
dass man jetzt immer einen test braucht
wir wollen ihnen einmal zeigen was
urlauber die nach mallorca geflogen sind
zum thema reisen gesagt haben und dazu
sagen was urlaub mit ihnen macht und
warum sie dorthin geflogen sind
ziemlich dicht machen und daher denke
ich möchte man auch so ein bisschen die
menschen einschüchtern ja dass die vom
buchen vom buchen abgehalten werden es
ist tatsächlich so ne dass es uns ja
auch sehr schwer gemacht wird auf die
insel zu kommen man sieht was hier los
ist und ich denke die gefahr in
deutschland ist größer wenn ich zurück
pflege muss ich ein test am flughafen
machen oder einem krankenhaus aber das
nehme ich gern in kauf
sie sind die gesetze diese selber
gemacht haben wo er sie gesagt haben war
keine einladung zum verreisen oder aber
es ist kein risikogebiet und wenn es
möglich ist dann fahren wir auch wenn
man sich an alle regeln hält was sein
problem ist dann denke spricht nichts
dagegen hier urlaub zu fahren der
flieger findet auch lächerlich habe ich
mir überlegt im flughafen sitzen sie vor
vor dem gate ja der halten sie abstand
und nebenan ist das restaurant das
genauso ist und das muss zu sein ja
warum also wo ist da noch die logik man
kann nicht das ganze leben einfrieren
wir sind ja getestet worden beim
einfügen
also beim vor dem flug das heißt im
flugzeug sind auch alle negativ das ist
ja so dass nur okay jetzt der rückflug
könnte natürlich ein risiko sein aber da
mache ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch keine
gedanken
wirklich nicht wir sind keine gefahr für
andere wenn wir zurückkommen und
trotzdem infiziert sind
dafür werden wir vorher getestet ja und
dann müssen wir in quarantäne sicherlich
wird davon abgeraten aber ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass jetzt wirklich
alles von der insel nach deutschland
jetzt fragen was hoffentlich werden wir
nicht mit eiern beworfen wenn wir am
düsseldorfer flughafen ankommen
was ist daran falsch jetzt auf mallorca
urlaub zu machen denn das ist ja das was
viele politiker in den vergangenen tagen
scharf kritisiert haben
ja das mag sicherlich nicht die
durchgängige meinung in der
bundesregierung sein aber ich sag mal
wir können die menschen reisen nicht
hindern
und wenn wir aber die voraussetzungen zu
schaffen dass jeder getestet zurückkommt
dann glaube ich ist das der beste
kompromiss
ich kann nicht jede meinung die sie
eingespielt haben von den urlaubern
jetzt teilen das ist schon eine
solidargemeinschaft die wir in
deutschland haben die einen fahren jetzt
in urlaub aber sie müssen auch
verantwortung für die gemeinschaft
übernehmen wenn sie wieder zurückkehren
wir wissen ja aus dem urlaub das nicht
nur ein strandspaziergang an urlauber
ausmacht sondern viele andere dinge auch
es hat nur zehn prozent der hotels in
new york kaufen
das sind strikte regeln es ist wieder um
17 uhr zugemacht aber es gibt sicherlich
randbereiche wo dann die stimmung etwas
besser wird und wie der abend etwas
länger das kennt man vom urlaub und da
müssen die die jetzt sagen sie wollen
unbedingt weg und in urlaub fliegen
auch ihre verantwortung für die
gemeinschaft in deutschland mitbringen
und das geht nur über einen negativen
test herr palmer werden wir hier über
mögliche reisen diskutieren spricht die
kanzlerin bei anne will die gesamte zeit
über ausgangs beschränkung schon fünf
sechs mal hat sie das in den mund
genommen auch bei der mpk war dass er
immer wieder thema sie sagt sinngemäß es
geht nur so wir brauchen diese ausgangs
beschränkungen sehen sie das genauso
das kann ich nicht beurteilen ob es
erforderlich ist aber ich merke schon
als bürger das ich nicht verstehe
also das ist einerseits möglich ist nach
mallorca zu reisen wo offensichtlich ja
keine ausgangs beschränkungen bestehen
das haben wir den bildern gesehen und
andererseits im heimatland dann
ausgangssperren diskutiert werden
das finde ich nicht schlüssig und da
sich als grüner ist auch nicht besonders
überzeugend finde das fern flugreisen
möglich sind aber übernachtungen im
schwarzwald oder im bayerischen wald
verboten weil die hotels geschlossen
sein müssen
das ist glaube ich auch ziemlich klar
deswegen meine ich die regeln müssten
dann schon irgendwie konsistent dass
sein also welchen ausgangssperren in
deutschland ein thema sind dann muss
eine reise ins ausland mit einer
quarantäne nach der rückkehr verbunden
seien in einem flughafenhotel denn wir
wissen dass dieser test nicht 100
prozent sicher ist der schnelltest
entdeckt nur 60 prozent der
symptomatische infizierten das kann also
immer noch zur übertragung kommen und es
ist auch möglich dass die infektionen
sich erst innerhalb von fünf tagen nach
der rückkehr entwickelt also meiner
meinung nach geht urlaub in anderen
ländern besonders mit höheren zinsen nur
dann zusammen mit ausgangs
beschränkungen und sperrungen zum hotels
in deutschland wenn nach der rückreise
quarantäne angeordnet wird wir brauchen
das schon regeln die irgendwie
zusammenpassen sonst gehen uns die leute
von der fahne
herr stöhr wir erleben die kanzlerin
spricht vor allem jetzt da noch mal
eingehen es ist schon ein bisserl
widerspruch ich teile die meinung von
herr palmer das ist durchgängig
erklärbar sein muss auch für die
deutsche hotellerie aber es sie haben
wir machen ja gerade die tests also wenn
sie die tests anzweifeln verdient sie
zurückkommen dann ist hängt das ist für
mich ein bisschen schief ich sage testen
ist jetzt die überbrückung für das
impfen egal wo man herkommt oder wo man
arbeitet oder ob man vom ausland nach
deutschland kommt oder sich innerhalb
deutschlands bei den testern setzt die
brücke und das müssen wir ausbauen
es sind genug tester sowohl schnelltest
als auch selbst erst vor allem für die
schulen und für die öffentliche
verwaltung alles besorgt alles in
ausreichendem maße da und
- 95% flugverkehr also - 95 prozent ist
jetzt mallorca das symbol dass
massenhaft dorthin geflogen werden ich
finde es nicht gut weil es gegen den
gemeinschaftssinn geht aber es gibt
welche die dorthin wollen aber dann wenn
sie zurückkommen
man muss auch der test anerkannt werden
wir wollen wir sie in tübingen ja auch
auf die bauen
ich würde es gerne aufklären was der
unterschied ist er uns einmal darf nicht
bei der bahn
ja also in einem fall geht es darum dass
ich menschen die ohnehin in meiner stadt
leben häufiger teste und ihnen dafür
erlauben wir mal mit maske und abstand
klamotten zu kaufen in der innenstadt
dadurch kommen keine zusätzlichen
infektionen in meine stadt
und dann ist es möglich zu akzeptieren
dass der test nur 60 prozent sicher ist
weil ich die sicherheit insgesamt in der
stadt damit verbessere
wenn ich aber menschen ins ausland
reisen lasse wo auch mutationen
unterwegs sind wohl das risiko größer
ist wie sie selber gesagt haben dass man
manchmal denn da feiert dann finde ich
das dann höhere sicherheit erforderlich
ist als nur die 60 prozent als
schnellstes und insbesondere dann wenn
man dem flugzeug auch noch dann die
sicherungs weiter verteilen kann wenn es
nicht erkannt wurde deswegen meine ich
da wäre eine quarantäne anforderungen
zur vermeidung der einschleppung von
infektionen und mutation absolut
notwendig und widerspricht der chemiker
test strategie nicht dass in zwei
verschiedene sachverhalte
ich möchte ihnen jetzt noch einmal
zeigen was die kanzlerin zum thema
ausgangs beschränkungen bei anne will
gesagt hat es ist das thema offenbar für
sie weiterhin und wir hören jetzt einmal
rein
für mich sind zum beispiel weitere
kontakt beschränkungen ausgangs
beschränkungen ganz wichtige mittel um
jetzt das exponentielle wachstum zu
stoppen herr stöhr wie viel sinn machen
aus ihrer sicht ausgangs beschränkungen
dieser phase in der wert sind
sind ergibt sich daraus wollt wenn man
schaut wo die hauptsächlichen infektions
orte sind es gibt gute studien jetzt
hamburg berlin dresden und aus bremen
die zeigen dass die kinder zum beispiel
nicht die quelle der infektion sind die
immer herbeigeredet wird
gebetsmühlenartig
aber es gibt natürlich gute zahlen auch
die ak ii veröffentlicht das in den
letzten wochen vor allen dingen in der
bevölkerungs bitte also den mittleren
altersgruppen die instanzen zu nehmen
und gleichzeitig sehen wir dass die
sterberate abnimmt
also und dann sehen wir dass die daten
die sind das in den all in den
pflegeheimen den familien und im
freundeskreis die hauptsächliche
infektions orte liegen und auf dem
arbeitsplatz es gibt 43 millionen
beschäftigte ist gibt zwölf millionen
kinder
ja wo soll man jetzt eigentlich
intervenieren wenn man das kausal machen
wollte müsste man tatsächlich drüber
nachdenken
die treffen in der familie im
freundeskreis zu reduzieren unendlich
aus dem arbeitsplatz schärfer
nachzuschauen
und dann kam ausgangs beschränkungen der
kanzler geht es darum eine konkrete
ausgangssperre
ausgangs beschränkungen von 20 uhr zum
beispiel bei 6 uhr
brauchen wir das jetzt in dieser phase
also ich bin kein soziologe
verhaltensbiologe oder population
mediziner aber als durchschnittsbürger
würde ich mal annehmen auch als
epidemiologe dass das eine möglichkeit
wäre die franzosen haben es gemacht die
haben die kindergärten schulen geschäfte
offen gehabt über eine lange zeit jetzt
eine sehr hohe inzidenz aber haben halt
eine ausgangssperre umgesetzt wenn man
kausal rangehen will dann muss man auch
dort ansetzen wo der hebel passt und die
ganze letzten monate wurde immer über
kinder gesprochen schulen
aber da kann man halt versuchen was zu
unternehmen und hat sich nie an die
heiße kartoffel getraut tatsächlich am
arbeitsplatz auch bei der familie zu
hause anzusetzen
aber man hat die menschen ja auch im
kopf verloren das war das entscheidende
und die panik diskussionen die jetzt
existiert eine frage nach wie die
kompetent erhöhten ich glaube ich hätte
passt aber auch nicht dazu erstellt ganz
konkret bevor wir dann die politische
diskussion weitergehen
was soll denn eine ausgangs beschränkung
von 20 bis 6 und tatsächlich bringt
also wenn man hier durch berlin durch
die straßen geht am abend dass er eh
niemand mehr unterwegs
das wird auch wenn dieser parlamentarier
monteurs kasten da sein soll wie es ist
nicht mehr so viel vorhanden
wo will man noch in den familien und
freundeskreis versuchen kontakte zu
reduzieren man hat hier viele menschen
im kopf verloren
da müsste man ja eigentlich die
eigentliche eigenverantwortung sehen die
menschen mitnehmen da was nicht mehr da
ist oder nicht zum großteil nicht mehr
da als muss man was andere versuchung da
könnte die ausgangs verschränkung helfen
aber dann muss man die soziologen die
verhaltensbiologen fragen aber da gibt
es auch dinge nicht wenig sagen die ich
gesehen habe
die die wirksamkeit so eine ausgangs
beschränkung belegen oder vorhersagen
könnte ich möchte ihnen herr buchholz
einmal zeigen was die kanzlerin unter
anderem noch zum thema berlin gesagt hat
und zu der frage was hier gerade
passiert
ich weiß jetzt wirklich nicht ob testen
und bummeln dies jetzt in berlin heißt
die richtige antwort auf das ist was
sich zurzeit abspielt also herr buchholz
die kanzlerin wirft hier uns berliner
testen und bummeln vor sich meint damit
dass eben die notbremse nicht geschaltet
wurde
ist das die richtige strategie jetzt
gegen die länder billigten da will ich
gar nicht so weit da bin ich gar nicht
so weit weg von der kanzlerin dass man
sagt werden man bestimmte hohe inzidenz
werte hat dann muss man regional auch
handeln und berlin hat in der tat hohe
werte berlin hatte zum beispiel auch
letztes jahr im oktober extrem hohe
werte und hat erst gehandelt
als dann alle gemeinsam mit einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz etwas
gemeinsam
irgendwie gemacht haben trotzdem
ignoriert die kanzlerin dass dieses
thema testen ein wichtiges thema ist und
im zweifel auch freiheiten schafft und
das was herr stöhr gerade eben gesagt
hat ist doch ein bisschen der schlüssel
zum ganzen
wenn man die akzeptanz der bevölkerung
nicht hat dann nützt auch eine
ausgangssperre nix von 20 uhr bis
morgens um sechs erreiche ich diejenige
die sich heute schon an alle möglichen
besuchs regeln sowie so halten die
dürfen dann abends nicht mehr mit dem
hund raus gehen und die anderen treffen
sich vor 20 uhr und bleiben gleich über
nacht das macht auch keinen sinn also
insoweit ist es wichtiger dafür zu
sorgen
akzeptanz erzeugt mittel und
möglichkeiten schafft dass man in der
tat private besucher vermeidet aber
trotzdem irgendwo ein bisschen beleben
kann
bei der urlaubssituation folgen aber das
beste thema wir alle sagen dass es nicht
mehr verständlich ist warum 130 flieger
nach malle dürfen aber an der ostsee
niemand irgendwo in einer ferienwohnung
leben darf das verstehen die menschen
nicht und ich verstehe es ehrlich gesagt
auch nicht wir hatten ein angebot
gemacht in der letzten woche zu sagen
leute lasst doch wenigstens aus dem
eigenen land oder aus dem angrenzenden
hamburg leute aus einem haushalt in
einer ferienwohnung gehen
das rp die tu berlin alle virologen
sagen uns da ist kein infektionsrisiko
und die leute die aus dem selben
haushalt in dieselbe ferienwohnungen
bringen kein zusätzliches risiko mit
wenn sie dann auch noch vor ihrer
anreise getestet sind am urlaubsort am
dritten oder vierten tag nochmal
getestet
wo ist das problem und weil diese
akzeptanz verloren geht werden immer
härtere maßnahmen ausgepackt die noch
weniger für akzeptanz sorgen in dieser
spirale wird es nicht positiv
weitergehen eher scheuer können wir die
menschen nach einem jahr pandemie
wirklich noch mit solchen harten
maßnahmen bekommt man die menschen noch
wenn man jetzt sagt jetzt machen wir
eine deutschlandweite ausgangssperre von
20 uhr bis 6 uhr morgens
also ich bin schon in der linie die herr
buchholz formuliert hat wir kämpfen ja
gegen das vergessen ihm in erinnerung
rufen dass man die politik gefeiert hat
im lok dann 1 dass wir eigentlich
weltmeister im chor ohne management
worden und dann ist uns irgendwo
befahren abgerissen weil wir auch im
oktober bei der zusammenkunft vielleicht
zu lasch waren da war mal kurz kurz auf
der zielgerade die haben wir schon ist
die zielflagge gesehen und dann haben
wir da zu schnell nachgelassen und haben
dann auch ein bisschen den faden
verloren das ist ohne zweifel so da in
deutschland keine fehlerkultur
zugelassen wird und dass jeder dann
besser als wenn aber im nachhinein
kommentiert wird
da nehme ich mich nicht aus aber wir
müssen nach vorne schauen und wenn ich
mir jetzt anschaue dass in meiner heimat
in ostbayern durch die grenznähe zu
tschechien überhaupt keine perspektive
geben gegeben werden kann weil wir uns
an die 200er an bewegen oder schon
drüber sind dann ist das was herr
buchholz sagt die ehrliche diskussion
darüber wie wir mit den mitteln die wir
haben sondern impfungen zum einen für
die regionen die besonders betroffen
sind kess hochfahren ganz massiv oder
wie gesagt jetzt beginnen wir ganz
massiv auch am arbeitsplatz neben home
office nochmal der appell für mehr
homebox ist aber vor allem auch das
thema testen am arbeitsplatz das würde
dann auch zum beispiel einer palme
helfen da brauchen wir einfach die
digitale schnittstelle wenn der um 10
uhr vormittags bei der arbeitsstelle
getestet ist dann werden wir es doch in
deutschland in bekommen dass ihr dass
dieser test auch für ein herr palmer
gilt in tübingen wenn der in die arbeit
neben den typischen dann zum einkaufen
gehen will oder sich später noch einen
kaffee kaufen möchte
diese aufgabe haben wir jetzt um die
heftigsten maßnahmen die noch im
werkzeugkasten sind möglichst zu
vermeiden und dann haben wir auch noch
das thema schon
wo wir nicht alleine auf der welt sind
sondern mit den vielen selbst erst
möglich gemacht wird dass wir vor allem
die sozialen härten abfedern
es würde sein ist doch bezogen darauf
dass momentan jeder gebannt auf die
zahlen schaut und dass wir alle
miteinander wissen wo die reise hingeht
für mandanten april ist für mich eher
tag wo wir die aufgabe haben als politik
gemeinsam parteiübergreifend die
perspektive zu formulieren
gebannt auf die zahlen schaut auch die
kanzlerin herr palmer und auch tübingen
ist im interview mit der kanzlerin ein
thema sie sagt dort wenn man sich
tübingen anguckt da gibt es keine
konstanz die stadt hat 35 der landkreis
75 gaukeln sie uns konstanz vorher beim
ich hab's die kanzlerin gesetze ihn
leider nicht gesehen
die letzte veröffentlichte zahl des
landkreises bezogen auf die stadt
tübingen war 35 das ist korrekt was wir
jetzt kurzfristig gesehen haben ist das
in drei schulen und kindergärten
ausbrüche aufgetaucht sind und in einer
landes ersten aufnahmestelle für
geflüchtete da sehe ich allerdings kein
zusammenhang mit theaterbesuch oder
einkauf im textilgeschäft deswegen
müssen wir dieses infektionsgeschehen
genau analysieren wir können noch nicht
wirklich sagen wie erfolgreich wir sind
wir können im moment sagen unsere zahlen
gehen nicht schneller hoch als die um
uns um das wäre zumindest schon mal
einen teilerfolg denn dann haben wir ja
zumindest die freiheit und das
stadtleben zurück geboten ohne auf der
infektions seite was zu verlieren und
dafür würde ich schon werben dass wir
uns solche modelle zumindest mal genau
anschaut und nicht voreilig verwerfen
wie das auch lauterbach getan hatte der
mann sagt jetzt kann ja sowieso nichts
werden denn die bereitschaft der
menschen jetzt in den nächsten richtigen
locker und so gehen die bröckelt immer
weiter das merke ich auch nicht mehr
weil geschäftsleute denen das wasser bis
zum hals steht sondern auch bei familien
wirklich bei allen wird es immer weniger
das sollten wir uns zumindest die zeit
nehmen das genau zu analysieren und die
kombination mit ausgangssperren übrigens
ist vielleicht gar nicht falsch was ich
auch feststelle ist mein größtes problem
das ich gerade
lösen muss ist dass ich abends nach 20
uhr 2 300 leute auf einer städtischen
wiese finde dieser halt party machen und
da gibt es keinen abstand sondern
alkohol deswegen ich hätte gar nichts
dagegen zu sagen ab 20 uhr ist wirklich
ruhe tagsüber wird geordnet in der
gastronomie außen gesessen ohne
infektionsrisiko und mit maske
eingekauft ohne infektionsrisiko und
getestet und nachts ich bitte alle
daheim warum nicht wir möchten noch
einmal ist es dann nicht sinnvoller zu
sagen an sammlungsverbot mit
alkoholverbot nach 22 uhr statt
ausgangssperre ausgangssperre trifft
auch die alte dame die um 10 noch mit
dem hund gassi gehen muss ein
sammlungsverbot mit alkoholverbot trifft
ihre 200 leute die sich illegal treffen
und das finde ich völlig korrekt und
genau darum geht dass verhältnismäßiger
vorzugehen und in einer anderen sache
hatte palmer aus meiner sicht völlig
recht wir müssen auch mal was probieren
und dann die erkenntnisse daraus ziehen
bei uns in schleswig holstein sind in
den meisten kreisen seit dreieinhalb
wochen die einzelhandelsgeschäfte
komplett offen hat das dazu geführt dass
sich unsere insolvenzen im lande
dramatischer nach oben entwickelt haben
mitnichten wir sind halb so stark
gestiegen wie der rest der republik was
lernen wir dann eigentlich daraus lerne
ist ich wollte ein buch aus 66 nationen
einmal bleibt eigen wie es in tübingen
aussieht in diesen tagen denn unsere
kollegen haben sich in tübingen
umgeschaut wie dort das leben weiter
macht und wie dort das leben anders ist
als in vielen anderen teilen
deutschlands
endlich wieder ausgehen feiern freunde
treffen in der uni stadt tübingen ist
das seit mitte märz möglich und gerade
wurde das modellprojekt um zwei wochen
verlängert das zieht viele auswärtige an
besonders junge menschen so auch am
freitagabend
ja es ist super hier schöne stadt das
bier schmeckt irgendwie das leben wieder
so zu fühlen das ist mal wieder los geht
und dass ich mal wieder das gefühl habe
auch leben zu können
die voraussetzung für den knallten
besuch oder einkaufsbummel ein negativer
corona schnelltest an einer der neuen
teststationen dafür gibt es dann ein
tagesticket entweder digital oder auf
papier kontakt verfolgungsbehörden
müssen gäste auch weiterhin ausfüllen
dann heißt es prost zur freude auch der
gastwirte die perspektive ist da und wir
blicken jetzt einfach auf unser geschäft
um auf die nächsten 14 tage drei wochen
und gehe ich davon aus dass wir da noch
gutes geschäft machen und drückt uns die
daumen dass es natürlich so bleibt
deshalb hat tübingens ob boris palmer
für den samstag auch leitplanken
eingezogen um das gedränge zu reduzieren
nur noch 3000 auswärtige dürfen
mitfeiern besser so als gar keine party
rund eine woche nach beginn der
öffnungen liegt die inzidenz in tübingen
bei unter 35 also weit unter dem
bundesdurchschnitt städte wie
ludwigsburg und böblingen möchten nun
nachziehen und ebenfalls modellstädte
werden
herr peymann bekommen richtig gute laune
wenn man die bilder sieht da aus
tübingen ganz vergessene zeiten
zumindest wenn man hier in tübingen sie
via sie sagen es richtig die kanzlerin
offenbar nicht warum schaut ihr so mit
argusaugen richtung tübingen und
gleichzeitig wenn sie sagen sie wollen
vielleicht sogar eine ausgangssperre
dann wäre es ja vorbei mit positives
über bis 20 uhr draußen sender
gaststätte kann man sein denn trinken
und irgendwann abends wird halt dicht
gemacht früher als sonst ich finde das
wäre ein guter kompromiss mit dem man
leben könnte was die kanzlerin angeht
kann ich sie nicht deuten dann müssen
sie im beruf in frage
aber es ist ziemlich offensichtlich dass
wir in deutsch
dann seit einem jahr eine strategie
fahren die nicht differenziert die immer
alle kontakte beschränken will und damit
halt auch meistens die falschen trifft
99 prozent der menschen sind nicht
infiziert und mein ansinnen ist
eigentlich seit mindestens einem jahr
lasst uns diese differenzierung
vornehmen lasst uns über tests und
kontakt verfolgung sicherstellen dass
die infizierten andere nicht anstecken
aber versucht möglichst wenig allgemeine
kontakt beschränkungen weil diese
massive auswirkungen auf das leben der
menschen haben und mittlerweile glaube
ich auch zu so groß und
ermüdungserscheinungen führen dass eine
kernschmelze in unserer gesellschaft
nicht mehr ausgeschlossen werden kann
und es ist eben auch für die existenz
eines gesundheitssystems eine
essenzielle voraussetzung wir müssen da
finde ich auch vorsichtig sein nicht nur
was das virus angeht herrscher können
sie sich erinnern wann sie das letzte
mal in einem biergarten in einer kneipe
oder im restaurant sitzen und wie
neidisch sind sie wenn sie sehen was da
hat in tübingen möglich ist geht das
bundesweit und wie gefährlich ist das
was er immer sagt drohnen sozusagen
diese beschlüsse ja zu einer
kernschmelze zu werden
also den letzten bürgern besucht kann
ich ihnen nicht sagen ich nehme mal an
das war im spätsommer oder herbst 2009
10 mutter braucht sind so lange waren
sie nicht mehr hören
naja also wenn wir seit märz 2020
diese maßnahmen haben wir haben herbst
ja mal wieder im sommer so ein bisschen
ja gut okay aber an sich nicht getraut
nein herr uns aber sie haben ja gefragt
vor der krise natürlich war im sommer
auch mal unterwegs aber das spielt jetzt
keine rolle wo ich unterwegs bin sondern
dass sich alle und die maßnahmen
enthalten
hintergrund ist dass momentan der
schwerpunkt ist auf öffnung und dass
jeder sich überlegt mir die öffnung
macht obwohl auf der anderen seite die
zahlen und strittiger weise von keinem
jetzt auch in dieser runde bestritten
erheblich und gefährlich steigen das
heißt dass wir das thema notbremse aus
dem blick verloren haben dass die
lockerungen natürlich gewollt sind wenn
sie irgendwo geht auch von der politik
wissen sie wir ich habe heute wieder
eine schalte mit ostbayerischen
einzelhändlern die haupt die natürlich
bei einer incidents von weit über 100
natürlich nicht aufmachen können
das führt zu ungerechtigkeiten wenn die
irgendwo lesen in schleswig holstein hat
man auch in anderen falls hat daraufhin
soll am hauptbahnhof und das macht uns
momentan diese diese bestimmungen die
der herr palmer mit einem schwierigeren
begriff kernschmelze betitelt aber ich
spüre doch dass auch und jeder ist jetzt
als politiker ja ganz besorgt darüber
was jetzt die richtigen schritte sind
wir haben mehrere gruppen
wir diskutieren jetzt zu sehen in dieser
runde über die lockerung möglichkeiten
und das was an möglich sind sie für eine
ausgangssperre feuer da haben sich ja
noch nicht festgelegt sind sie jetzt für
die ausgangssperre bundesweit ja weil es
schon im beschluss der mpk drinnen steht
ich hätte da kein problem damit ich
glaube in der tat so wie gesagt dass es
momentan auch viele private feiern gibt
die wir alle zusammen nicht wollen in
große ansammlung und wenn ausgangssperre
beschlossen ist dann glaube ich auch ist
jedem klar wie dramatisch die lage ist
und dann hat es auch für die
ordnungsbehörden einen ansatzpunkt das
normale leben ist doch unser thema es
ist doch nicht das thema nach 22.30 uhr
noch ein bierchen zu trinken sondern das
normale leben dass man mal flanieren
kann dass man spazieren gehen kann
das ist doch unser thema wenn der ball
mal sagt er hätte auch damit kein
problem die eine oder andere der eine
oder andere kamera schwenkt aus tübingen
hat mich schon etwas besorgt gemacht
weil auch beim herr palmer die die
zahlen steigen werden aber hintergrund
daran ist dass das normale leben
untertags mit besorgungen mit einkaufen
auch mal wieder in ein
bekleidungsgeschäft gehen mit mine
konzepten dass man den einzelhandel
perspektive gibt dass man natürlich der
außengastronomie perspektive gibt aber
das geht nur wenn wir jetzt die nächsten
tagen und wochen die richtigen maßnahmen
der vernunft machen dann können wir die
perspektive möchte noch einmal zeigen
mein leben wurde wurden so schon immer
wieder gesagt
jetzt heißt es wieder den nächsten 14
tagen müssen wir durchhalten und dann
wird alles gut also das geht ja nun
schon die dir sterben weiter von einer
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zum
nächsten
ich stimme ja zu das was getan werden
muss aber die argumentation wie ich
wieder auch von herrn steuer höher
nämlich das ja wir müssten eigentlich
überall das gleiche machen
und eigentlich ist die inzidenz zu hoch
ist wieder zu undifferenziert wir sehen
tatsächlich eine zunahme bei den kindern
wurde doppelt so viel getestet wird
aber welchen einfluss hat das wir sehen
eine zunahme bei den erwachsenen 43
millionen beschäftigten
ja das hat vielleicht eine andere
bedeutung wie der abnahme des trends bei
den indoor sterberate sind weniger als
100 menschen gestorben
zum glück und hoffentlich bald noch
weniger das sind zehn prozent der
sterberate von noch zum zug die zeiten
im durchschnitt also was sind ja auch
positive trends und da können wir die
menschen auch gezielter mitnehmen wenn
man auch darüber sprechen aber die ganze
zeit zu reden über die virus mutante
turbo virus und auch fälschlicherweise
auch noch nicht mal die deutschen daten
hierzu verwenden die hier vorliegen
finde ich nicht richtig und auch wieder
das allgemeine
undifferenzierte wir müssen die
gesamtzahlen unterbringt wir werden
höchstwahrscheinlich die gesamtzahlen
nicht unterbringen aber wir können
sicherlich durch testen und durch mehr
den menschen auch eine perspektive geben
diejenigen wieder zurückholen ins boot
die jetzt sagen ich habe die nase voll
ich mache jetzt nicht mehr mit und
verdacht das ist mein in meinem
fachgebiet eben von der pandemie
konzentration auf die risikogruppen auf
die haupt kontakt orte und das sind ohne
zweifel die familie und der
freundeskreis und wenn da mehr getan
werden kann werden die fälle auch
zurückgehen da werden die
intensivstationen weniger belastet wären
wir haben ja wieder 3500 das 1000 mehr
als in der 2 in der ersten welle im
letzten jahr
die zahlen sind nicht toll aber man wenn
man jetzt alles und differenzierter
betrachtet werden und ihnen hohe meldet
in thailand als einzige zahl verwendet
dann werden wir wirklich die leute nicht
mitnehmen können
ich möchte dich schon mal richtig möchte
ich schon richtig stellen
ich habe gerade von den verschiedenen
regionen geredet ich mein ja was der
partner gesagt hat gesellschaft die
vorgänge die auch durch mediale
begleitung und berichterstattung in
einen in schwere innere kämpfe bringen
ich sag noch mal in meiner heimatregion
wir sind zu tschechien eine region die
schwer gebeutelt ist und da muss ich
auch fähig seine perspektive zu geben
ich möchte nicht alles über einen kamm
scheren und über die deutschlandkarte
der selbe machen aber sie sind doch
biologe sie müssen doch auch sehen dass
ohne zweifel die zahlen jetzt gerade
wieder dramatisch nach oben gehen und
das aber nicht machen wir wieder so
allgemein sagen sie es doch nicht dass
die zahlen so allgemein hoch gehen
natürlich sehen wir melde inzidenz die
ansteigt aber gleichzeitig sehen wir
auch eine sterberate die abnimmt der
inzidenz bei den alten abnimmt
wir sehen gleichzeitig eine horizontale
bewegung beziehungs leichter anstieg in
den mittleren altersgruppen
aber das ist die stärkste population
stärkste gruppe wir sehen eine
verdopplung der der intensität der
testung bei kindern
wir haben gute daten von schulen und
kindergärten jetzt
die zeigen dass dort die incidents nicht
zunimmt in bremen in dresden in hamburg
und auch in berlin wurden kinder
getestet 80.000 in hamburg die inzidenz
sie dort gefunden wurde testung aller
kinder liegt bei 136 einer größenordnung
die gesamt incident in hamburg liegt in
derselben größe obwohl dort nicht jeder
getestet also vier oder fünfmal mehr
erste mission control konzentriert
angehen und ich würde hoffen dass die
kindergärten und die schulen nicht in
diese diskussion jetzt hinein kommen
sondern wirklich die leute die die die
infektionen jetzt weitergeben und die
zwei anderen möchte ihnen noch einmal
zeigen was die kanzlerin gerade eben zu
der frage gesagt hat wie wir diese
pandemie meistern und vor allem dass wir
aus ihrer sicht schon in einer neuen
pandemie stecken
wir haben im grunde eine neue pandemie
und deshalb muss noch einmal diese kraft
aufgebracht werden damit wir dann auch
den imf erfolg haben aber bis dahin muss
das was wir als mittel kennen kontakt
beschränkungen notfalls ausgangs
begrenzungen home office ich kann es
jetzt nur noch mal wiederholen
ganz entschieden durchgesetzt werden
japaner ganz entschieden durchsetzen
kontakt beschränkung ausgangs
beschränkungen home office das sind ja
die instrumente die wir tatsächlich seit
monaten ja eigentlich fast seit einem
jahr hören oder
deswegen frage ich mich kennt die
kanzlerin die effektive kontakt
verfolgung mit moderner digitaltechnik
nicht oder warum kommt die nie bei ihr
vor dem instrumentenkasten wir könnten
längst racing apps haben und sie jetzt
aktivieren jeder kunde freiwillig
entscheiden aber diese daten preisgibt
ich habe auf meinem iphone
selbstverständlich die aktion findet
mich aktiviert weil es wiederhaben
möchte wenig verlieren das bedeutet dass
apple zu jeder zeit eine gps daten hat
finde ich völlig okay ist mir allein
besuchen des iphones wert warum könnt
ihr mir nicht auch die gesundheit
anderer das wert sein dass sich die
daten einfach freigeben und damit dann
auch die frage mal geklärt wird wo man
sich ansteckt darf ich am steuer auch an
einer stelle recht geben das ist mir
gerade wirklich wichtig die bilder die
sie da gesehen haben am freitagabend
haben auch mich besorgt das war
eindeutig zu viel die gab es aber nur
einen einzigen tag deswegen habe ich
gestern 20 uhr alkoholausschank verbot
angeordnet und durchgesetzt ja so kann
es natürlich nicht geben das ist aber
wir versuchen sie müssen herausfinden
was geht wo sie einschreiten müssen und
es waren überwiegend überwiegend
auswärtige die nach thüringen gekommen
sind
dachten sie können jetzt party machen
dann muss man halt eine grenze ziehen da
haben sie recht es war zu viel ist
angekommen in palma aber dennoch die
spannende frage warum wir weiterhin
sozusagen die instrumente benutzen die
wir seit einem jahr kennen herrscher sie
sitzen auch im carola kabinett dabei
warum sind wir bei der digitalisierung
nicht längst weiter warum sagt die
kanzlerin wieder die üblichen begriffe
kontakt beschränkungen ausgangs
beschränkung home office das kennen wir
alle seit monaten seit jahren und
darüber dachten wir doch wir sind in
einem hochtechnologie standort hier in
deutschland ja da haben sie recht
ich bin der digital minister und ich
muss ihnen sagen jetzt wollen wir uns so
gut auch ergänzte palma immer wenn man
sagt bitte der kompromiss muss doch sein
damit ich mehr grundfreiheiten
zurückbekommen muss ich vom thema
datenschutz auch kompromisse eingehen
das ist gerade wenn ich an die grünen
denke oder auch an die fdp
da machst du einfach und sagst du pass
auf das ist jetzt eine zeit wo man durch
müssen schaffen wir es eine nationale
kraftanstrengung der digitalisierung in
bezug auf die bekämpfung der der korona
pandemie hinzubekommen auch eine bessere
nachverfolgung damit auch das möglich
ist was zum beispiel jetzt in tübingen
möglich ist und da drehte ich voll dafür
ein wir brauchen jetzt endlich die
schlauesten köpfe damit wir und da bin
ich vielleicht ein bisschen falsch
verstanden worden nennt jetzt nächsten
zwei wochen wieder dramatische maßnahmen
beschreiben und die nächsten drei und
vier wochen und wenn ihr das nicht macht
dann wird kriegs nicht gut diese diese
diese ansagen sind das sind die
bürgerinnen und bürger sind solche
ansagen leid das was wir jetzt machen
müssen ist die praktische umsetzung der
digitalisierung zur bekämpfung der virus
pandemie und es geht nur wenn jeder von
sich aus ein bisschen was von seiner
datenschutz und ja dieser typisch
deutschen herangehensweise an die
digitalisierung etwas zurücknimmt damit
man mit modernen mitteln erschaffen den
bürgermeisterinnen und bürgermeistern
landräten den behörden die
nachverfolgung so zu ermöglichen dass
sie damit arbeiten können und virus
bekämpfen können aber gleichzeitig auch
freiheiten möglich sind und dass nicht
doch da und schutz rechtlich andreas
scheuer da muss ich doch gar keine
zugeständnisse machen
das regelt doch einfach die möglichkeit
der einwilligung wenn ich als bürger die
möglichkeit haben zu sagen will ich das
will ich mir diese freiheiten nehmen und
nehmen dafür eine beeinträchtigung
hinten hat der parade gesagt beim iphone
machte das erweist dafür dass seine
daten bei apple sind wenn ich eine luca
hat mir runter lade weiß ich dass meine
kontakte im zweifel als bewegungsbild
nachgezogen werden können will ich das
ja wenn ich ein williges noch alles in
ordnung wir müssen noch mal dazu kommen
dass wir nicht immer die
die vollmilch liegende sonst was sie
wollen und bevor wir eine app
konstruieren alle möglichen sachen da
rein hermann sondern einfach mal
pragmatisch vorgehen und sagen leute
lasst uns das nachverfolgung thema
einfach auf eine sinnige art und weise
machen und behalte oder einbildung ist
alles okay
herr buchholz haben wenn wir sagen wir
haben jetzt geschafft am freitag ein
modernes personenbeförderungsgesetz sind
digitalen zeitalter einstimmig durch den
bundesrat zu bringen das würde ich mir
bei mancher tracing app oder
möglichkeiten und hilfsmittel für die
gesundheitsämter auch wünschen das ist
nämlich nicht so bernd dass man so nur
selber freiwillig die nachverfolgung ein
klick sondern die ämter brauchen
natürlich auch das rüstzeug dazu diese
möglichkeiten zu haben und das immer
sicher rechnen über die möglichkeiten
der scheuer größere möglichkeiten oder
sehr große möglichkeiten hätten wir auch
wenn es mit dem impfstoff hier in
deutschland besser funktionieren würde
insbesondere im vergleich zu israel
großbritannien in den usa sie alle
kennen die debatte der vergangenen
monate jetzt hat sich die kanzlerin bei
anne will zum thema impfstoff
folgendermaßen geäußert sie hat gesagt
ich wehre mich dagegen dass beim
impfstoff blauäugig gehandelt wurde
insgesamt was bestell umfang und was uns
zur verfügung steht haben wir gut
gehandelt herr palmer hat deutschland
beim impfstoff gut gehandelt
das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen ich
glaube wir haben da an der falschen
stelle gespart und wir haben die
bürokratie ist auf die spitze getrieben
wenn man weiß dass die zulassung in
europa auch die frage des quer oder
hochformat von tabellen betrifft und
gestern den zurückgemeldet musste sie
das korrigieren müssen um die zulassung
zu erhalten und wenn man weiß dass wir
so viel zeit verloren haben weil wir die
haftung unbedingt bei den herstellern
verorten wollten statt die einfach mal
auf uns zu nehmen wie das die usa
gemacht haben dann ist ja ziemlich klar
dass die firmen zuerst mal dahin
verkaufen wo sie nicht haften müssen und
das ist einer der gründe warum europa so
wenig impfstoff bekommen hat nein ich
finde diese einkaufsstrategie
nicht richtig und sich für sie über
demokratie ziert und an der falschen
stelle sicherheitsorientiert und ich
würde mir wünschen nach vorne betrachtet
das jetzt korrigiert wird dass wir das
amerikanische prinzip der zulassung
wären dann nutzen größer ist als der
schaden will
ich finde es sehr seltsam dass ich weiß
dass in meiner stadt millionen impfdosen
produziert wurden die nicht verimpft
werden können obwohl die technologie bei
biotech und moderner die gleiche ist und
die technologie in tübingen auffinden
wurde aber jetzt halt nochmals separat
diese ganzen zulassungs bürokratischen
durchgezogen werden müssen unser
impfstoff in der dritten welle deswegen
nicht zur verfügung steht ich würd sagen
wer bereit ist ihn zu benutzen das so
hinbekommen ich habe ihn auf die art und
weise gespritzt bekommen als programm
auch da wir auf freiwilligkeit lösung
ich bin sicher millionen menschen würden
sagen bevor ich das risiko der infektion
ein gehe nehme ich mir jetzt im dem
kuhberg impfstoff und bringen sich in
sicherheit
heuer haben wir bei uns mit dem impfen
und zwar wie es mit dem impfen
tatsächlich geklappt hat kann man doch
einfach schlicht am ergebnis ablesen
es gibt bei den g20 ländern tatsächlich
viele die noch schlechter sind als wir
aber es gibt auf der welt einige sind
deutlich besser als wir
die amerikaner sind besser es sind die
briten besser oder sind die israelis
besser und wenn man sich an den anderen
orientiert sind wir ganz gut wenn man
sich an den besten orientiert sind wir
nicht gut
herr bucher sie möchte noch einen
weiteren satz vorlesen in die kanzlerin
gerade gesagt hat zitat das ihr alles
schlecht läuft das geht auch nicht wir
müssen uns wieder mut und kraft zu
sprechen es ist nicht alles schlecht es
gibt keinen grund in sack und asche zu
gehen
da bin ich ganz dabei ich bin immer ein
permanenter optimist ja es benutzt uns
überhaupt gar nichts nur nach hinten zu
gucken aber es nützt auch nichts die
dinge zu beschönigen und deshalb muss
man jetzt mit optimismus daran gehen wir
haben eine phase vor uns in der
hoffentlich größere impfstoffmengen
wieder ins land kommen dann auch
pragmatisch zu verhinden dann so schnell
wie möglich den impfstoff auch gegen die
menschen zu bringen ich mag sich in den
usa anderer im lebensmittelladen am
eingang jeder der den oberarm nicht
rechtzeitig wegzieht kriegt quasi eine
impfdosis darein dass es noch völlig
andere art und weise als bei uns das
muss vielleicht in dieser form auch
nicht sein aber es geht darum dass
durchaus da auch licht am ende des
tunnels zu sehen ist und den optimismus
will man nicht
ja aufgeben ich plädiere dafür so
differenziert wie möglich auch
vorzugehen endlich zu lernen aus
bestimmten dingen der pandemie und nicht
so zu tun als sei jetzt eine neue
pandemie entstanden sorry aber ich sehe
keine neue pandemie ich sehe dass wir
mit den instrumenten arbeiten wie vorher
ich sehe allerdings auch dass wir über
bestimmte strecken dazu lernen mussten
erst waren die masken gar nichts thema
dann die masten ganz wichtig dann ist
das alles haben wir doch dazu gelernt
und jetzt wissen wir eigentlich auch wie
wir mit bestimmten dingen umgehen müssen
handeln wir endlich danach und dann ist
mir auch nicht bange dass wir
durchkommen werden aber immer mit dem
holzhammer auf alles drauf zu holen das
wird eben die akzeptanz der leute nicht
erschaffen und deshalb werden sie aus
büchsen und das wird das
infektionsgeschehen treiben holzhammer
sie sprechen es an die kanzlerin ist
auch wütend darüber dass viele
bundesländer unter anderem hier auch in
berlin die notbremse nicht anwenden die
notbremse bedeutet dass alle öffnungen
bei einer instanz von über 100 dass dann
die notbremse gilt und zum beispiel
klicken miet und andere dinge nicht mehr
so möglich sind möchte ihnen einmal
zeigen was die kanzlerin dazu im
interview bei anne will gesagt hat es
war ein kompromiss und ein kompromiss
mit treu und glauben darauf dass die
notbremse auch wirklich umgesetzt wird
wenn sie das jetzt nicht wird ist das
sozusagen ein verstoß gegen die
beschlüsse die wir getroffen haben
eher scheuer was sollte passieren mit
den ländern die diese notbremse nicht
umsetzen die kanzlerin hat nicht nur
berlin angesprochen
unter anderem hat sie auch zum beispiel
nrw kritisiert ja notbremse war wirklich
fix vereinbart und auch wenn man jetzt
darüber wie vorher intensiv darüber
diskutieren kann dass die dann wird er
ganz deutschland gilt
aber ich glaube in der tat dass wir den
15 april im blick haben müssen und bis
dahin muss sich jeder am riemen reißen
aber es geht hat er sehr sehr
unterschiedlich auseinander in den
einzelnen regionen
und wenn ich das mal sagen doch den
fängt schon mit impfungen zusammen weil
sie ja angesetzt haben mich zu fragen
und dann hat mein buchholz seine
sichtweise
eingebracht aber natürlich es hat zu
lange gedauert
wir müssen jetzt bei den genehmigungen
und den freigaben schneller sein
auch von impfstoff der uns vielleicht
anfangs als testballon vorgekommen ist
stichwort sputnik wir müssen da
schneller sein
wir müssen pragmatischer sein start
perfekt und wir müssen schneller sein
und flexibler sein um diese
herausforderungen anzunehmen so und bei
den lieferungen wird jetzt auch
hochgefahren als wird 3,54 millionen 5
millionen jede woche kommen und sagen ja
schon die ersten ja das können wir gar
nicht für impfen also das darf uns
definitiv nicht passieren vom eine
extrem ins andere
und so kommt es mir oft ein in
deutschland vorher einen lebens andere
ich sage die notbremse stand und die ist
fixer einbaut
und die geht einher mit dem impfen wenn
wir diese diese instanzen jetzt in den
griff bekommen um die zeitlichen schiene
noch mal hochzufahren mit dem impfen
und wenn man nicht impfen kann vorher
testen und das auch mit einer
nachvollziehbarkeit dann kommen wir
dadurch herrscher sie sprechen die
extremwerte an was die pandemie angeht
auch die werte für die cdu erreichen
immer neue horror tiefen heute 25
prozent und die kanzlerin wurde darauf
auch angesprochen in diesem interview
und sie hat dann gesagt die cdu hat
keinen rechtsanspruch auf das kanzleramt
das andere auch regieren wollen ist ja
klar
was bedeuten diese sätze ja ich stelle
jetzt immer fest dass dich die meisten
wiederum sitzen in diesen konferenzen
schön mal wegducken schön mal auf die
kanzlerin staaten und wenn man ein
grüner ministerpräsident ist wenn man
als fdp in einer koalition ist wenn man
auch ein vizekanzler ist und
kanzlerkandidat dann tut man sich erst
einmal weiter und lässt mal schön
angela merkel machen und natürlich haben
wir die auswirkung dieser
unzufriedenheit zu spüren weil natürlich
spürt jeder ich auch in meinem wahlkreis
dass die leute einfach ungeduldig sind
und durch viele viele extrempositionen
immer wieder sagen diese krise wird
schlecht gemanagt was ich an vielen
vielen stellen nicht nachvollziehen kann
und einige stellen sicher
aber jetzt müssen wir kämpfen alle
wollen gegen die union gut dann wären
wir den kampf annehmen
zu diesem thema möchten wir noch einmal
mit reinnehmen den cdu chef von berlin
burkhard träger der uns schon zugehört
hat herr drescher wenn sie das hören was
die kanzlerin dort sagte die cdu hat
keinen rechtsanspruch auf das kanzleramt
dass auch andere regieren wollen ist ja
klar
und ja das waren die antworten auf die
frage ob die politik von angela merkel
der cdu der union das kanzleramt kostet
haben sie auch diese sorge dass sie am
ende in ein paar monaten raus sind aus
dem kanzleramt
also sorgen habe ich viele aber ehrlich
gesagt wir arbeiten nicht jetzt in
dieser pandemie bekämpfung um
wählerstimmen sondern unsere aufgabe ist
es die gefahren von unserem land unseren
menschen abzuwenden
das ist unsere heilige schlicht und da
muss es prioritär gehen
und deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir
gesundheitspolitisch das notwendige
machen dass es die eine seite der
medaille
auf der anderen seite der medaille ist
das was das an konsequenzen hat für
gewerbetreibende für alleinerziehende
eltern deren kinder im home office im
fernunterricht sind und die das im
office regeln müssen und wir müssen
diese gratwanderung hinbekommen beides
zu schaffen wie bisher ja auch die
gesundheitsschutz zu wahren und ehrlich
gesagt ich dachte das mal sagen die art
und weise wie deutschland seine bürger
geschützt
aber er trainer wäre das kanzleramt
verliert der verliert ja auch die
gestaltungsmacht
keine sorge ich glaube wir sollten uns
um die krise kümmern
warum uns nicht um - aber umsonst
kümmern sie sich nur schlecht dürfen
sich als 20 kurzen endlich erfolgreich
sein werden aber eher drecker bei einem
aspekt und die krise kümmern sie sich
eben aus sicht der menschen schlecht bis
miserabel sonst würden sie ja nicht bei
25 prozent stehen
also ich will nur mal sagen die
ministerpräsidenten haben sich bisher
unter dem mantel der kanzlerin versteckt
er hat alle wesentlichen entscheidungen
getroffen und das hat dazu geführt dass
dieses land jedenfalls
gesundheitspolitisch hervorragend seine
bürger geschützt hat jetzt gibt es
weiter
sie wird sich tatsächlich darüber moment
moment hatte ich mich bleiben mal
ausruhen aber dass sie wenn sie sagen
dass die bürger hier hervorragend
geschichtet so auf den punkt zu sein ja
aber wenn sie sagen sie wurden
hervorragend geschützt also wenn sie
sich anschauen wie wenig menschen im
vergleich zu anderen ländern geimpft
sind dann wollen sie ihn nicht
hervorragend geschützt ich möchte mal
darauf hinweisen dass wir zu keinem
zeitpunkt unser gesundheitssystem
überfordert haben zu keinem zeitpunkt
mussten ärzte die entscheidung fällen
wer auf der intensivstation behandelt
wird und wer nicht sondern diese
schlimmsten gefahren sind abgewehrt
worden
und das ist nicht selbstverständlich
wenn sie sich in den internationalen
vergleich gegeben
dennoch will ich ja gar nicht nur davon
reden ich möchte gleichzeitig darauf
hinweisen dass wir die möglichkeiten die
wir heute haben nutzen müssen um
freiheiten wirtschaftliche betätigung zu
ermöglichen
deswegen freue ich mich über die
modellprojekte auch das in tübingen ein
paar mal habe ich es schon gut geschätzt
freue mich ihnen jetzt wieder zu sehen
und wir können doch daraus lernen und
der dass wir diese lernen die lehren
auch beherzigen müssen ist ja klar aber
sie müssen auch verstehen
die kanzlerin hat mit den
ministerpräsidenten am 8 märz
vereinbarung getroffen und es ist schon
erstaunlich dass er alle mac laufen
jetzt und sich an diese vereinbarung
nicht mehr halten und ich möchte
folgenden vorschlag machen sollen auch
die ministerpräsidenten bis zur nächsten
runde am 16 april oder wann die iss ihre
ein alleingangs versuche man machen und
dann werden wir sehen was passiert
ich kann nur sagen seit dem 8 steigende
tendenzen und wir werden dann sehen wo
wir mitte april stehen und dann möchte
ich die diskussionen sehen die dann
geführt
wird und ich glaube so lange sollte die
kanzlerin den ministerpräsidenten
auch die die möglichkeiten lassen zumal
rechtlich gesehen die kannst du also
keine möglichkeiten hat das zu verbinden
befugnisse liegen hier bei den ländern
und die länder versuchen wir uns zum
ersten mal selbstständig zu gehen
ich bin gespannt was dabei rauskommt ich
kann nur sagen für berlin wo ich als
oppositionsführer tätig bin dass hier
noch nicht einmal die schnelltests an
den schulen angekommen sind die schulen
aber geöffnet worden sind und da wundert
mich überhaupt nicht dass berlin
plötzlich wieder ganz oben nicht bei den
lizenzen und wenn das hier so
dilettantisch wie in berlin weiter geht
und nicht so wie thüringen
beispielsweise das hervorragend gemacht
wird dann wundert mich überhaupt nicht
dass wir mitte april einer situation
sind die wir nicht beherrschen können
möchte dass die scheiben darauf kommt es
an
ich möchte noch einmal zeigen was die
kanzlerin zu dieser speziellen frage
eben der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in
dem interview mit anne will gesagt hat
deshalb bin ich auch nicht für eine
vorgezogene mpk jetzt im augenblick in
diesen tagen die dieses ringen wenn wir
wieder zusammenkommt dann muss klar sein
dass dort gemeinsame ergebnis
herauskommen es müssen ergebnisse
herauskommen
was erwarten sie davon in den nächsten
tagen in den nächsten wochen was wird in
deutschland passieren keine mpk mehr
herrscher oder wie können jetzt
gesetzliche regelung geschaffen werden
auf jeden fall keine ad hoc mpk weil die
ganzen werkzeuge und instrumente ja da
sind wir brauchen ja überhaupt nicht neu
was beschließen weil wenn man etwas
beschließt und keine hält sich dran also
die koordinierung der so genannten h
seite der spd länder soll dann auch ein
neuer regierender bürgermeister in
berlin übernehmen der sitzt er da auch
im gleichen raum mit der kanzlerin
da erwarte ich mir schon dass eine form
gewählt wird dass man am zwölfter april
nicht in der findungsphase ist weil es
nämlich die nächste mpk sondern vor dem
zwölften april fest steht dass man
innerhalb von maximal zwei stunden alles
fix und fertig beschließt dass wir die
richtige herangehensweise aber mpk
sitzungen sind der teilweise so
findungskommission und das ist natürlich
ganz daneben sondern wir brauchen an
dieser stelle einen klaren fahrplan er
einfach formuliert es keinen
beipackzettel von 17 seiten sondern zwei
seiten genügend mit ganz klaren
botschaften und wenn sich daran jeder
hälfte auf dem richtigen weg ich sage
ihnen
das eine ist der kampf gegen das virus
und das was man hier das land machen
auch als cdu csu sind wir da massiv in
der verantwortung klar aber was ich dort
teilweise parteipolitisch erlebe da
schreiben ganze vizekanzler
fragenkatalog im eigenen corona kabinett
jetzt kann ich einfach nicht verstehen
und diese vielstimmigkeit hat der ganzen
politik geschadet
und jetzt müssen wir vertrauen alle
zusammen zurückgewinnen die die nämlich
jetzt gerade ein bisschen aufholen und
vielleicht ein bisschen wind bekommen
die wir uns dann büßen wenn wir im
wahlkampf sind und das vertrauen in die
ganze politik konterkariert ist und
deswegen möchte ich ihre einigkeit in
dieser schwierigen phase und das
brauchen wir am 12 04
aber das ende auf 17 10 sondern nach
zwei zeit selbst schon noch mal
zurückkommen wir müssen noch mal
zurückkommen auf diese auf diese
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und auf die
tatsache warum die so laufen
die sind nämlich schlecht vorbereitet in
wahrheit und diese schlechte
vorbereitung liegt auch daran dass aus
dem bundeskanzleramt oder so auch drei
stunden vorher oder ein laden am späten
nachmittag vorher dann erster beschluss
vorlagen bedingung an landesregierungen
geschickt werden wo man sagen muss jetzt
14 tage nicht darüber gesprochen und
dann kommt doch irgendwas dabei raus und
dann wird in der tat darauf solche
findungskommission die dann auch völlig
irre sündige beschlüsse fassen weil
einer buchhandlungen auch gut findet
sind plötzlich bücher gegenstände des
täglichen lebens bedarfs- und werden am
dritten märz plötzlich mit dazu erklärt
weil irgendeiner sagt jetzt muss aber
über ostern noch richtig was scharfes
passieren entsteht so eine oster ruhe
diese mpk es müssen anders vorbereitet
werden auch so vorbereitet werden dass
sie im zweifel mit den jeweiligen
kabinetten in den ländern abgestimmt
werden können was beim letzten mal
überhaupt nicht der fall war
da konnte man über das thema oster ruhe
vorher überhaupt nicht reden das war
auch nicht bekannt das war mal eben in
die luft geschossen solche dinge sind
einfach vom teufel
deshalb sage ich mal es muss darum gehen
mit vernünftiger vorbereitung diese
dinge voranzutreiben an einer stelle
allerdings das will ich auch ganz
deutlich sagen
mit einer notbremse die beschlossen
worden ist kann man umgehen
wir haben in schleswig holstein einen
sogenannten
dallas da ist ganz klar dass neben der
verordnung gibt es eine erlassen müssen
alle kreise die über 100 gehen sich mit
dem gesundheitsministerium rückkoppeln
und die entsprechenden maßnahmen
vereinbaren das kann man einfach
schlicht und ergreifend machen führt
dazu dass eine stadt wie flensburg die
kurzfristig deutlich über 100 war dann
wieder unter 100 ist heute und dass man
das wieder herunter führt wenn man
allerdings in den ländern dann einfach
zukunft und sagt ja ist dann halt so
lassen sich jetzt aber weiterlaufen weil
wir uns nicht trauen
jetzt auch die entsprechende
konsequenten beschlüsse da muss man sich
nicht wundern
also in dem land wie schleswig-holstein
mit einer inzidenz von immer noch unter
70 kann man glaube ich allerdings auch
eines sagen ja dieses land hat sich
nicht versteckt hinter irgendeiner
kanzlerin
wir haben nie gesagt dass wir nicht
selber irgendwie unsere beschlüsse
fassen wollten wir sind beim letzten mal
er mit dem was wir machen würden
zurückgepfiffen worden weil wir gesagt
haben wir würden gerne bestimmte dinge
auf eine art und weise mehr akzeptanz
schaffen machen da ist dann die sitzung
unterbrochen worden um gottes willen so
kann man das nicht machen also dass
länder hier keine verantwortung
übernehmen worden ist ein märchen aber
vorbereitung ist notwendig vorbereitung
ist notwendig das gilt auch für den
urlaub aller deutschen und da gibt es
eine große diskussion was den sommer
angeht und in unserer abschlussrunde
würde mich interessieren
herr palmer der kanzleramtsminister hat
gesagt urlaub erst ab august wieder
möglich und auch nur dann wenn wir uns
an die regeln halten haben sich schon
mal über sommerurlaub nachgedacht oder
lieber nicht
und doch tatsächlich wir haben im
oktober am gardasee mal versucht
jüngsten was zu buchen
mal sehen im moment glaube ich auch
nicht dran dass das gehen wird und im
august möchte ich gerne auf den
friesischen inseln sein das wird in
landesminister freuen denn die sind ja
glaube ich sogar im moment corona
freiheit so ohne weil sie jeden der mit
der fähre kommt da auch testen ich hoffe
dass zumindest dieser zweite urlaub
stattfinden kann
herr stöhr wenn sie hören dass der
kanzleramtsminister sagt keine
urlaubsreisen vor august wie schwierig
wird das dann mit den sommerferien
also er hat noch dazu gesagt dass die
die sommerferien nur dann kommen wenn
die neue mutanten sich nicht mehr
weiterentwickelt und er hat auch noch
gesagt da für uns jetzt noch den letzten
14 tagen zusammenreißen müssen und dass
das passiert also dass wir das sind die
leute nicht mit was ich sehe und was
kommen wird ist dass die sterberate
weiter abnimmt
die ist ja jetzt schon unter 100 zum
glück nach april werden auch die über
70-jährigen geimpft sein das heißt dann
über 90 prozent der todesfälle können
verhindert werden
und ich glaube auch nicht an diese
herdenimmunität die so wie wikis kann
melde inzidenz durch die ganze
population geht sondern wenn die über
50-jährigen geimpft sind
dann sind im prinzip mehr als 99 prozent
der todesfälle verhindert dann kann es
gut noch ausbrüche von respiratorischen
erkrankungen ein oder schwer im sommer
geben auch viele aber dann muss man
wirklich sehr kritisch über diese
öffnungs schritte nachdenken ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass wenn das
passiert dann so viele geimpften dass
man da nicht sehr schnell zur realität
zurückkommen muss man kann sich nicht
noch weiter abkoppeln und und paradoxe
para mi pandemie evaluierung machen wir
jetzt andere länder gehen mit höheren
instanzen um haben die geschäfte
geöffnet und deutschland werden doch ein
bisschen in sonder kurs die anzahl der
todesfälle die sterberate ist in england
in portugal und auch in irland niedriger
als in deutschland auch die gesamtzahl
der fälle ist niedriger england braucht
man sich nicht wundern die haben jetzt
viel mehr impfung aber warum in portugal
und irland
obwohl dort die variante wir fast 100
prozent ausmacht also die gesamte
artikulation wir müssen uns
zusammenreißen richtig warum variante
finde ich nicht konsequent aber ich
glaube im sommer wird es dramatisch
besser werden ist eine saisonale
erkrankung zum großteil und ab ende
april hoffentlich ja wenn es wärmer wird
da wird das auch nur eine rolle spielen
als ich bin da eigentlich relativ
optimistisch gebucht habe ich für mich
noch nichts ich will mal sehen wie das
weitergeht
herr buchholz sommerurlaub erst ab
august wenn die deutschen dem
kanzleramtsminister folgen
und wenn
die sozusagen so vorgehen dass wir für
schleswig-holstein doch schon zu spät
oder deutlich und der tourismusminister
von schleswig holstein der ich ja auch
bin sagt das muss auch nicht sein wir
müssen uns dahin tasten genau wie herr
palmer ein modellprojekt für eine stadt
macht müssen wir im tourismus werden die
residenzen jetzt nicht dramatisch
explodieren mit modellprojekten zeigen
dass tourismus verantwortbar geht mit
tests zu hause bei abreise mit dem test
nach drei tagen am urlaubsort mit
konsequenter kontakt nachverfolgung mit
dem test grund getestet sein müssen bei
betreten der gastronomie in und so
weiter
diese dinge sind möglich ich hab ein
modellprojekt ausgeschrieben da bewerben
sich zurzeit ganz viele regionen in
schleswig-holstein darum ihr wollt das
allerdings seriös machen indem wir nicht
wieder ans im saarland einfach mal die
ganze region zur modellregion erklären
sondern indem wir die voraussetzungen
klären mit den jeweiligen regionen die
bewerben sich und dann werden wir
wahrscheinlich zwei drei modellregionen
machen um zu zeigen dass tourismus auch
schon vor dem august in deutschland ganz
gut funktioniert und verantwortbar
umsetzbar ist er träger wo geht es für
sie heraus aus berlin was haben sie
geplant für den sommer und glauben sie
dass das was wird
wir haben keine pläne ich möchte auch
jetzt ich würde mich freuen wenn man
jetzt schon den glauben und die hoffnung
auf den sommerurlaub nimmt ich sehe
dafür auch keine veranlassung nicht nur
weil ich optimist bin sondern weil ich
glaube dass wir sehr große fortschritte
erzielen werden bis zum sommer und
deswegen ist es die falsche botschaft
jetzt den menschen sozusagen den urlaub
könnte jetzt schon abschreiben
das darf nicht sein und wir können schon
gar nicht erklären dass man urlaub auf
ausländischen ferieninsel man kann aber
nicht im eigenen land das versteht
keiner und hier erwarte ich auf ein
umdenken bei allen handelnden wir müssen
jetzt wirklich die chance nutzen ich bin
gespannt was die projekte auch die
modellprojekte ergeben ich hoffe sehr
dass sie erfolgreich sein werden und
wenn sie erfolgreich sind dann haben wir
eine menge gelernt und dann können wir
sie auch größenordnung mäßig ausrollen
darauf hoffen eher scheuer zum abschluss
wie sieht ihre urlaubsplanung aus und
als verkehrsminister was glauben sie wie
viele flugzeuge können im sommer wieder
durch die welt starten was ist möglich
kann ich ihnen nicht sagen aber ich sage
ihnen medien weniger angst und mehr
hoffnung und das geht nur wenn man an
die verantwortung appelliert wenn man
vertrauen hat
auch in die tonne übten regeln und wir
brauchen regeln verhaltensregeln aber
auch die notwendigen instrumente
beispielsweise auch der nachverfolgung
und der test strategie aber wenn 50
millionen das hat er die kanzlerin auch
gesagt bei anne will
wenn dann im sommer 50 millionen
impfungen erfolgt sind dann haben wir
eine ganze palette an möglichkeiten
unterwegs zu sein ich hoffe im eigenen
land weil das wird wieder in hotels und
den gastronomen helfen aber ich bin fest
davon überzeugt dass es nur mit zwei
buttons auf der app geht nämlich
der eine ist der button impfen das heißt
der nachweis dass man die ems und der
zweite ist mehr noch nicht geimpft ist
die testungen um dann es möglich zu
machen in einem restaurant zu sitzen
oder in einem hotel zu buchen
ich habe jetzt noch keine konkreten
pläne aber das wird sich noch ergeben
als auch weniger angst mehr hoffnung
und zusammenrücken in der gesellschaft
dass brown wird weniger angst mehr
hoffnung sagt der verkehrsminister ich
denke ein schönes abschluss wort auf das
wir uns ja einigen können an diesem
abend eine besondere sendung die
richtigen fragen vor allem im hinblick
auf das interview der kanzlerin und vor
allem im hinblick darauf was hier in den
nächsten tagen in den nächsten wochen
passiert ich bedanke mich bei meinen
gästen und ich kann ihnen sagen dass wir
hier bei bild genau weiter verfolgen
werden wie es politisch hier weitergeht
und vor allem in den nächsten stunden in
den nächsten tagen der nach der frage
nachgehen werden was plant die kanzlerin
denn nun wirklich